this is the hemlock Prep Academy debate
club how many members do you have - she
and I her and I her and myself
him and me myself and I me I've already
forgotten what club you're here on this
is a vehement hatred if we're gonna get
anywhere this year you two have got to
agree on something
forget about her you just need to focus
on getting into Yale you'll qualify for
the state tournaments and Harvard will
give you a fluoride you're the best
debaters in the county together you
could qualify for state does anyone not
ready for fast mean debate everyone
started speaking fast to get both points
well you can't understand what you're
saying you can't you can nobody can you
have no chemistry we disagree and
strategies this is your future and you
are going to win we all know who is
carrying this Dave I think Lana deserved
it you should all feel that way about
our kids right it's good to see you Amy
good luck to your daughter it's not
about luck Julia I do things by myself
this thing where we study together I
don't think that's what I'm gonna I
disagree of course you disagree
disagreeing is what we do best
[Music]
my whole life I've hated you not because
I knew you but because I thought you
hated me too
I don't think we were ever really high
schoolers I was too busy with homework
tests and debate many extremely
successful people who got into their
dream school where they didn't but all
of them went on to do stuff maybe I'll
help me get into school maybe it won't I
just I want to win let's play
[Music]
you
[Music]